I don't have a question. I just have a comment.
I just hope the people won't be afraid to have confidence in the
rife machine. I've been doing this a long time and my
cancer didn't happen just overnight and it's not going to
go away just overnight. But I was supposed to be dead according
to the biopsy in February of 2018. And here I stand, just
getting ready to go, put my chickens up for the night. I've
worked most of the day. The days that I don't feel well. I
just figure it's the toxins in my body and I know I've got
to go detox. But there are most days that I don't even remember
that I have cancer. The days that I've cheated on my diet, I'm
paying for and I know what I mean I've been doing this long
enough that I know that it's what I have put in my body. So I
guess what I'm just trying to say is I believe this works. I've
never had chemotherapy. I've never had radiation. I still have
the tumor. I can see it. I can feel it. It's shrinking. So I
just hope people will get hope from this that it might take
a while. I can handle it. If it takes another five, 10 years, it
slowed me down some, but you know what, it's not stopped me. So
I'm not telling anyone not to go hiking. That's not my message, my
message is the rifle works. Well, thanks, Chris. So I
appreciate that. So when I put this zoom presentation together, I
had considered whether or not by me sort of revealing some of
the, some of the gaps that can happen that people might feel
discouraged about the rifle machine. But I guess one of the
main things that I'm trying to do through this is to show
people that that the rifle machine is an incredible tool. And
it's really the real, the primary pillar that we've really
built our clinic around. And there's no way that we're ever
going to stop utilizing the rifle machine as long as we are
allowed to manufacture them and sell them because of the amazing
things that we've seen happen. But the reality behind it is
that just like every single thing in this life that is, that
is touched by humans is that there is an element of imperfection
that comes with it. And that even though we do our absolute best
to get as close as we can, that there can be, that there can
be holes in that perfect intention. And so, you know, it's
the same thing with everything that we try to do. We want to
aim to live life in excellence. But that doesn't mean that
it's always going to move forward perfectly the way that we
would dream or the way that we that would, you know, we desire,
you know, God tells us that that man makes his plans, but that
God's going to direct his steps. And, and so we make a plan on
the way that we're going to put together this rife program, the
way that we're going to try to come alongside our patients
to the best of our ability to help them move forward. But that
ultimately beyond that, there are elements of this that can be
beyond our control. And that will do everything that we can to
come alongside our patients. But when we approach using the
rife machine as if it is the magic tool that is going to cure
everything, we can be feeding ourselves a misnomer, and we
can be setting ourselves up for some disappointment because
there are things with the rife machine that can be tweaked and
can be changed and enhanced so that we can get closer to what
each of our patients need if they're seen that the original
rife program doesn't seem to be helping them as much as we can.
And that being said, we could tweak it again and again and
again. And if their body or their cancer is not something that
we can get behind, then it might not be something that we can
get behind. So there's just this balance. There's this balance
of living in reality and also living with this hope and with
this trust that we're doing everything that we can. That's
right to be able to boost our immune system and push it
forward and overcome this horrible disease. So I'm so
grateful for your words and your wisdom, crystal and your
guidance. I greatly appreciate that. And I also hope to that
what I was saying is not a discouragement to people, but it's
just again, a reminder that that we are humans trying to help
other humans and that I am not a cure all and Dr. Connors is
not a cure all and the rife is not a cure all. But we're going
to do every single thing that we can to try to come along
side you and help you if you reach out to us and you ask us
for it. And and hopefully that will allow us to to have more
people have an experience like you, crystal, where you're
able to look back and go multiple years ago, I wasn't even
supposed to be here, but look at me now and look at the journey
that I'm walking on. So thank you so much.